iq les faits qui nous sont reprochés
sont graves et j'ai conscience par
conséquent de l'exigence de réponse et
d'action attendu de ma part ainsi 2
ainsi que de celle de monsieur jean
christophe remercie nos directeur
général pour la france présent à mes
côtés devant vous ce matin je mesure
également et avec moi les collaborateurs
d'orpea la gravité la souffrance
l'émotion la colère mais aussi la
stigmatisation et l'opprobre que chacun
d'eux subie à tout instant depuis des
jours des semaines alors qu'ils doivent
prendre soin des aînés que nous leur
confions
je ne vous dirai pas que le groupe
d'européens n'a rien à se reprocher je
ne vous dirais pas que nous sommes
coupables de rien
la mission conjointe de ligier a fait de
l'igas à la suite de la publication du
livre nous a fait des reproches si grave
et pour sapin nous avons répondu point
par point à ces questionnements
légitimes nous avons reconnu des
dysfonctionnements pour certains est
inacceptable même si le rapport
définitif permet de conclure qu'il n'y a
pas de système organisé qui aboutirait à
une maltraitance généralisée et dément
clairement les allégations les plus je
me compte du livre nous regrettons
profondément ces dysfonctionnements et
nous tenons à présenter nos sincères
excuses aux résidents et à leurs
familles mais il ya dans ces attaques et
ces reproches beaucoup de choses
inexactes et injuste et c'est aussi
notre devoir de le dire de les démontrer
comme nous l'avons fait dans les
réponses au rapport de la mission
conduite par les deux inspections
les semaines et les mois qui viennent
seront j'espère l'occasion pour le
groupe de nous expliquer et de nous
défendre mais aussi de nous a demandé et
de prendre des décisions pour repartir
de l'avant
ma tâche est ma responsabilité sont de
sortir le groupe orpea de la tourmente
dans laquelle il est plongé aujourd'hui
tous les reproches ont cédé 6 régularité
qui ont pu nous être ou qui nous sont
reprochés
dont certains sont à virer trouveront
des réponses et des solutions
changement comportement changements
parfois de lignes directrices et bien a
vendu nous vous confonde nous nous
conformerons à toute injonction
administrative et judiciaire
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir nous ne
limiterons pas nos efforts à réagir ou
nous défendre dès aujourd'hui
j'annoncerai une série de mesures
précises et concrètes pour rétablir un
foncier et si un fonctionnement efficace
et fiable d'orpea vis-à-vis de toutes
les parties prenantes et ainsi redonner
confiance à nos résidents c'est leur
famille à nos salariés aux pouvoirs
publics et à nos actionnaires ces
mesures sont la première amon amorce
d'un plan plus vaste de transformation
du groupe que nous allons annoncer en
mai prochain à la lumière des résultats
de nos audits externes
[Musique]